Hello and welcome. It is September 12,
2023. We're here in the Active Inference
for the Social Sciences course at the
Active Inference Institute and having a
discussion section on semiotics and
semantics here with Lorena Sganzerla.
We're going to be having a fun
discussion, I hope. If you're watching
Live, please feel free to write any
questions in the Live chat. If you
thought about joining and you weren't
sure, it's not too late. Otherwise,
we're going to pick up on some key
points from the lecture and on the topic
and see where we go. So,
Lorena, welcome back
and however you want to begin,
let's go from there. Okay.
Hello. Thank you, Daniel.
So let's try to recap a little bit where
we left off during
the lecture just
to remind us where we were. Like, my
point, what I was trying to articulate
was the idea of what does
it mean to talk about a formal semantics
in a way that is not really loaded
because it's an interesting thought.
Like to have a semantics
that is actually only formal, right? In
principle, it would be relative to
meaningful to
meaning, right? In the notion that
active inference is trying
to cash it out.
It's more like an idea or a way of
modeling how we deal
with meaningful situations.
And to understand that in a
more interesting, more embodied and more
concrete way. I was suggesting that
we could use biosemiotics as a
as a model and as a theory for
living creatures like language users to
navigate the realm of symbols.
And gave one example which
came from James
Cott, which is the European
forestry that comes with a practice
understanding this scientific
understanding of forests as a practice
that allows us to
refer to meaningful things
in the environment in terms of what is
valuable, what's interesting and what is
not and interestingly,
what is more important also from what
becomes valuable. It is what is
cropped out from the meaningful
perspective. So things natural
parts of nature becomes left out or
understood as something that is not
desirable. And you just understand what
you don't want in your articulating
principle as wheats or something that
you should get rid of in
respect to what is more desirable in
terms of crops and how you understand
nature in a more commoditized
way.
And I find, like this example from Scott
kind of very elucidating in
the book. He creates this in the book,
he's talking about states how we
articulate life around one specific
notion of state. But in this specific
example, he has the idea of one official
observer. And this official observer
establishes a principle of meaning
in a way, you have to have a handle
of nature, and that also articulates how
villages and how practices
around agriculture and
how people relate to each other within
these practices gets organized
specifically for one interesting
point that he makes that is to
appreciate the constriction of that is
like a vision that notices not what
within the meaningful crops, but which
is left outside the field of vision.
And I bring that specifically to
understand how the
fragility principle can or could
be connected to a generalized
synchronization over time in
relation to those symbols and those
practices in terms of niche construction
and how
this niche construction brings along
with the symbolic use of language,
predictive value.
Thank you. Brynn, want to bring up any
thoughts on that or any other pieces or
I'm happy to add a comment.
Brynn okay,
guess not. Okay.
A lot to say there. There was a little
bit of a double play with what is
cropped. On one hand, what is cropped is
the industrial crop that is being
prepared.
And then the other side of that coin is
what is cropped out. And what we crop
in is the part that we're paying
attention to and we can't pay attention
to everything. So it's like two sides of
the same coin. What we pay attention to,
what we include in attention in our
cognitive awareness, leaves the shadow,
which is what we exclude.
And that could be like the weeds or
the other ecosystem services. So by
highlighting the meaning or one
dimension of meaning or one stance on
meaning, it's like
a seesaw that becomes salient to the
extent that something else must be
deprioritized. So that's how we
accentuate these distributions of
meaning. And what do we get from active
inference and free energy principle
beyond, for example, what's provided in
seeing like a state? I think there's a
lot we could say on that. But one piece
is we get a process theory, a real
procedural approach to how different
systems come to do sense
making and cognition and action. So just
describing the lay of the land or the
history of forestry in Europe or any
other state of affairs in the world,
merely describing it may not even help
us determine what's going to happen a
short time later, let alone a long time
later, or what might happen in a very
different ecology. Whereas if we
understand the processes of sense making
and decision making that different kinds
of cognitive agents do, certainly humans
also though states as cognitive
entities, which is what seeing like a
state or thinking like a state entails,
we get a process based view on
what otherwise might be merely
descriptive. And along with that process
based view, we gain an increased ability
to make unique explanations,
predictions, accounts, and so on.
Yeah,
we can also understand
it in a different perspective in
terms of realizing what becomes
sensitized and what becomes desensitized
along the process. So you can possibly
model that using these kind of tools and
understanding how that happens over
time. I don't know how much
in terms of prediction of things that
were not foreseen in these descriptions,
we can achieve. In fact,
you can achieve some level for sure,
but that system should be decide
how that delivers a very all
encompassing prediction. In this case,
I don't believe it can. Right. I don't
think that's the purpose as well,
but we can at
least have which might not be as
positive as we want, but I think we can
understand how we
can gain some understanding in this
process of being more sensitive or less
sensitive to specific primes
and how these organizational principles,
how powerful they become over time.
Yeah, I'll read some comments in the
chat and then Lorena or Brent feel free
to just give any thoughts. Just upcycle
club wrote hello. Biomimicry can enhance
biosemiotics by showing us how nature
solves problems and creates beauty
through signs and codes and by
encouraging us to apply these principles
to our own creations.
Yeah, the idea of
coding is an interesting idea, but to
talk about codes, I don't think that's
my take. Right, I don't understand. We
haven't coded any type of principles
within our cognitive
ability. But biologically
speaking, however, you can understand
these encodings in terms of becoming
more or less sensitive over time to
environmental cues as the example
in terms of I use the example of
forestry. Right. So in that specific
case,
what? You become more sensitive and the
more you organize your life, or social
life is organized around specific
principles. Then you can make sense of
these relational stories instead
of just leveraging one full difficult
to explain notion of encoding in
terms of social cognition because it
will be hard to explain how the brain
will be encoding these specific symbols,
but they can be cashed out in the
environment relationally in terms of
those organizational principles. And
then you have this idea of biomimicry
like this reiterations and how that
comes along to
explain what this mimic or this meme
will be then not so straightforward,
I think. Well, certainly decompiling
the source code of nature is somewhere
between challenging and misguided or
impossible. But that notion of a code
script for biology has animated
discussions of life, going back to, for
example, Schrodinger's. What is life?
He basically says there's two aspects of
living systems. There's their
organizational capacity, their
negantropic capacity, and then there's
their code script, their Apyotic
crystalline informational repository.
And then another place that coding comes
up a little bit less in the source
code space is predictive coding.
And that's in a way highly compatible
with active inference and gives a
deflationary account on how the
semiotics are encoded. Rather than
saying, well, this is what this variable
in the source code means, or this is
what this codes for, or here's a code
switch, predictive coding is like saying
we're not even going to touch the
semantics of what the sign is itself.
We're just going to hypothesize that the
way that information about the sign is
transferred is through this maximum
information signaling approach called
predictive coding. Because predictive
coding arose out of video compression
algorithms and only at the end of the
90s was found to be increasingly
relevant for neural circuitry and so on.
So it's another example of where like a
process based approach
ends up deflating or
reframing the otherwise
semantically loaded question.
It's like switching out the question of
where we're going to be with how we're
going to get there. And instead of only
focusing on the meaning of the signs
first off, as if the meaning of the
signs could be discussed outside of
their implementation. And then even
if we could figure out what the signs
were, we would then just turn around and
want to know how they were transmitted.
And so predictive coding or predictive
processing in a way short circuits that
or inverts it by first looking to
explain how information is transmitted
that could support semiotics and
then in the context of biological
systems we naturally have biosemiotics.
Yeah, I would ask the question when you
talk about information being transmitted
right, what that actually means. And I
think that's a very big topic and a very
large discussion in terms of information
theory when specifically applying that
into biological systems.
I think there are some interesting
people working on information that makes
the case that Shannon has a point and
he's really interested not in
the semantics or in the meaning or
anything else. He's kind of interested
in the problem of transmission. And when
you talk about transmission, it's worth
to ask what is being transmitted exactly
in the terms of signals, even if you're
capturing specific patterns and you
think that the pattern is the thing that
will be transmitted in that sense.
But that will be a
worth asking question to understand this
notion of what is actually being
transmitted in that sense. This
information theory is focusing on this
notion of the problem of transmission
and then all the concepts that come
along to explain that in terms of
uncertainty or noise and everything that
impacts these transmissional processes.
And if
you're saying like we're transmitting
information in this sense that is
breaking this semantic code
apart yes it is. Because the problem is
not focused on that. It's that focusing
on the specific correlations that we
have that we call they were mentioning
as information and how these
correlations are an issue
from the get go, from what is being
picked up in one side being correlated
to what comes into the other side.
How do you lose or gain more information
in that? But the
deeper question here is how
can you say that you are actually
gaining or losing that information
because you are defining this
correlation that could be transmitted or
not from the get go? If you don't have
that, you don't have anything being
actually communicated.
So with that in mind, you can explain
these concepts in terms of function,
and then there's a bunch of theories
that navigate this sense of signaling
that is specifically only functional.
And then predictive coding tries
to push that a little further, maybe.
But then you have to explain in
a deep sense how this information is
being actually transmitted and
processed. And I don't think that is
really as obvious and as clear as we
think it is.
Specifically when we're talking about
this biological way of nature,
navigating this signaling we
have to talk about because the
correlation, if it's defined abenishi
from the beginning, then only have this
kind of transmission for someone
specific that can be able to understand
that in the other side. Right?
Well, certainly whether we're talking
about a chemical pheromone that
requires some type of receptor or
something more ephemeral like language
that requires more of a semantic
reference frame, there's no receiving
the message without the sender. It's
like they're kind of the two sides of
the phone call. I'll ask a question from
the chat? Love evolve.
How about cultural encoding and
principles in contrast to
organizational? So how do we think about
cultural meaning?
And is that similar or different than
organizational?
That's a good point. Right. I think if
you take very seriously the example from
the forestry is a practice,
then I think it has to be
organizational in that sense, the
meaning navigate this organizational
practice, this organizational story that
impacts not only
communication between agents but also
how the environment will be interpreted.
In this sense, it will be transmitted
and repeated over time because it has a
history. You cannot ignore the history
of these practices being pushed further
and replicated through generations.
Right. So the
way the villages will be organized
in terms of that specific practice, for
instance, can be understood in a
meaningful and cultural way that
organizes life in virtue
of some specific
principles that sensitizes
our agents towards specific directions.
And I think I
don't know if you get my point.
For instance, you can talk about,
if you think about archaeological
findings and how archaeological
descriptions of specific villages and
how they navigate this mapping out
these archaeological sites.
They usually know exactly if you have
some kind of history already from these
communities, how that city will be
likely to be organized. First off,
where is the water? And if the water is
in certain directions, probably there
will be certain kinds of relationships
with housing and communal housings and
where they're going to place their dead
in relation to this kind of specific
organizational principle. The water is
here, so plantations will be not so far
away from that. And the city organizes
like the village organizes a little bit
in this sense and that builds up
cultural practices, at least
archaeologically, can be explained as
such. I thought
of something similar organization
being the logistical or the operational
structural aspects. So those would be
the roads that connect the forestry
outposts or the circulatory system that
connects the different organs of
organization. And then the culture is
a cause and a consequence of
organization. Organization is
the enabling conditions for culture to
arise. Okay, so given this road network,
what cultures arise? How similar or
different are they convergently? What
are their practices or their narratives
that are shared amongst these different
outposts? Or in the bodily example,
okay, given the organization of the
organs, literally the organizing process
or principle, then what biosemiotics
can arise with glucose and insulin and
glucagon? And what culturally can arise,
maybe even in terms of the generative
model of encultured agents as
a function of organization? And then
what do those encultured agents do to
the extent that they can modify
organization? And so these kinds of
unrolling cause and consequence
relationships can be hard to disentangle
because there's not like a clean single
starting point that can be
separated out or because it unfolds
historically,
it's not exactly a
reaction in a test tube.
So how does active inference give us an
entry point into thinking
about this? Yeah,
that's one interesting thing about
active inference that you
don't really need an origin point,
right? You can start modeling and start
understanding that at any given point
and build up from that story and see how
it unfolds over time.
I think that's the most beautiful idea,
that you define your parameters and then
you see from that parameters that can be
arbitrarily defined and you can navigate
how things change within those
parameters in the generative model,
right. When you have your dynamical
systems, for instance, you have your
state space, they have some specific
range of defining
parameters that set the limits
of the possible states that you're going
to navigate. And if you use this notion
that these two densities brings about
in terms of Bayesian modeling, you can
use these kinds of tools to understand
how from that specific parameters update
what we narrate in active inference,
as if belief updating can change over
time in these terms.
That's a very nice point. It reminds me
of Bruno Latour's Actor Network Theory,
or Ant, which kind of advocates a
similar approach to what you described,
which is like enter anywhere open
mindedly, because in an Iterated
modeling or Iterated analysis setting,
the first proposal or the first trace
detected, we know that's not the whole
picture. There may not be a whole or
only picture. So we need to enter and
iterate and then with active inference,
specifically because of the
compositionality that we get within a
layer, collective behavior, and then
also the kind of nesting smaller things
inside of bigger things, we can always
build something and then we can go,
oh wow, it's like there's a lot of top
down influence. Maybe there's a higher
order factor or slower factor or a
contextual factor we should consider or
oh, we were abstracting across these
smaller things inside. But for a later
day or if relevant, we can dive in.
And so then it
allows a light hold or a grasp
on the proposed generative model.
Obviously, it's map, not territory. But
even beyond that, we always know that we
can expand laterally and across scales
starting from anywhere in an Iterated
modeling process without our first
or even 11th model being proposed
as, like, the accounts of some complex
cultural phenomena which we're always
going to only ever have our own
perspectives on. Yeah, I think you don't
really find that in being so all
encompassing. Like you have one model
that will model them all.
You can navigate those models in these
more instrumental terms. It raises
different questions when you put things
like that in terms of geontology of
models and models and theories and
sciences, but they can be also described
as tools
for describe tools for grasping
and describing phenomena in
a more non committal way,
how much that how much
that smuggles in philosophical
or moral ontological problems. It is
still, I think, under debate, but it
is still told. You bring insights to
think about specific cultural collective
phenomena, which is not it's complicated
because I think what I'm getting at,
I'm kind of like going back and forth.
But when you talk about social sciences
and modeling, usually you have ways of
modeling modeling agents or ways of
modeling collectives and active
inferences, trying to come
up with a modeling in which you can
understand agency and collectives within
the same modeling schema.
And I think specifically for these
cases, if you're interested in
understanding types of cultural
phenomena among language users in
specific contexts, you can at least
partially understand or gain some
insight in this agent collective
relationship that is a
little bit more interesting than we have
found so far in the social sciences,
because you can have our specific
understandings of memes. But then how
the agent? Where is the agency in that?
You lose a little bit of agency when
you're trying to understand only
agents. Then you don't know how that
kind of scales up because active
inference tries and offers these scale
free modeling tools that
facilitate this conversion
into agents and collectives.
I would be interested in asking you,
actually, how do you navigate that when
you talk about social phenomena in
ants or termites?
Because then you have very specific
coding demarcations, I guess, for these
social environments.
Yeah, it's a great question. It's also
whether it's an open wound or
a dirty closet that's just shut.
There's actually a lot of ambiguity and
unresolved tension around.
Well, is the ant colony social?
Are they social insects that reifies the
nest mate as the individual? And then
what they're doing is like when we hang
out and talk. So reifying the nest
mate as individual makes the colony
social. But if the colony is individual,
then what nest mates are doing with each
other is not social any more than we
would describe the liver and the kidney
as having like a social single cellular
interaction. But we know that would be
missing the point. And so there
definitely is attention with some of
these evolutionary lineages, like ants
being monophyletically obligate usocial
all. And only ants are
eusocial they all live in the colonies.
There's no free living nest mate whereas
other parts of the evolutionary tree
there are life histories that
do look a little bit more like social
collaboration that can then dissolve.
And so knowing what level of lock in
makes something social.
When are we socializing? And what level
of lock in goes beyond social. And it
kind of like makes when the blanket is
so strong around the social that
like for multicellularity that
it's kind of losing the social feature
again because if we just use social
to mean the connective tissue or the
kind of lubricant or the spaces between
everything, then it means
nothing. So a real
tension is what space
does the social account for?
And is this going to be a concept
with a lot of creep looking? Well, it's
a social relationship between the roots
of the tree and the fungus and it's a
social relationship amongst the
molecules in the test tube. Is that too
broad of a social conception?
Are there downsides or
are there trade offs associated with a
broader social concept? Do we dilute
what the social means? And then on the
other side, might we exclude phenomena
that could importantly be considered
social? Well, that's not social,
they're just talking on a train. It's
like well that's the other side. If we
were to have carving out encounters
that we do want to include as a social
and is there a true social?
Does active inference help us sidestep
or at least negotiate this territory?
Because we could develop a generative
model or an ecosystem of shared
intelligence with one person and
two internet of things devices and a
bird and a metronome and
just say we made what we made and then
leave it as a second order
interpretation whether that is a social
setting.
I mean, I think you are pointing at the
granularity of those scales, right? If
you have a model that one to one to
everything that you already have, it's
probably not interesting and not
informative because you cannot define
those limits of what you're trying to
understand. And in the other hand, when
you do that, when you define those
limits, if you're too narrow or you're
going to leave out you're going to
idealize also in a way, right, and leave
out many other parts of the system that
you're interested in. But if you don't
do that,
if you don't make this decision, if you
don't make this decision when modeling
anything then how you can
have any access to the
phenomena, right? And to connect this to
the forestry so in the forestry example,
the desirada was lumber.
Now that may have been a very narrowly
scoped desire, but it's a relevant
thing to want this resource. And then
industrialization science as a process
professionalization those allowed the
description and the handling and
ultimately the kind of top down
legibility and control thinking like a
forestry company. Now with respect to
the social sciences by analogy to
forestry science. So now we're entering
an era of increased legibility and
control of social systems and
human natural capital and attention as a
resource, trust as a resource in
a way is being cropped analogous to
produce the content of lumber. But now
there are social contents. So as the
social goes from being just only
simply the water we swim in. Not
something that's even compared
counterfactually to alternative cultural
possibilities per se, but falls under
the scope of the professional
management. Like forestry then
that's. When this discussion of, well,
what's the lumber and what is the weeds
that are being pruned and what ecosystem
services, when we pay attention to
certain parts of human social culture,
and when we seek to make more of this
kind of lumber,
what else does that come along with?
And what decisions come
into play. That comes along
when you see the process?
Or Instagram? I don't know. Twitter?
After what happened to Twitter.
But yeah, in terms of attention
pruning, you do have that very
effectively already happening. You can
see how that happens efficiently in the
voting elections for instance. It can be
very easily manipulated and we saw what
happened in elections for instance in
Brazil or in the well
all over.
You navigate a system of attention
organization that selects in only what
he thinks that your interested in,
in the effect of that in terms of
decision making and in terms of trust,
in terms of diversity
of discourse, we have seen that it can
be devastating.
The question would be like how can
you use active inference and these tools
that we have to make this kind
of technology a little bit more
inclusive without being super, also
disruptive? Is it even like
a possibility? I really don't know. I
think it's an ethical problem that we
have when we talk about social systems
and these principles of attention
exclusion, leaving things out.
Lot to say on that.
With modeling and interpolating and
models, whether it's large language
model type or linear regression type,
it is able to interpolate
to put data points within an enclosure
of what has already been described. And
Bayesian statistics and other types of
prediction algorithms are not immune to
that either. If we have some prior
distribution belief, we believe
it's possible for it to be between 20
and 30 degrees outside.
Then when we get data inside of our
bounds we can converge
and that actually tightens our beliefs.
Not always a bad thing of course. And
then outside of the scope of the
possible, those data are just seen as
noise and they may not even be
integrated. So then that can lead to a
reinforcing process, not necessarily
an adaptive one either, where
information that's confirmatory is used
to ratchet and increase precision and
then information that is not
confirmatory is discarded as not
useful.
In this case it doesn't even enter the
landscape of attention of the
user.
What I was thinking in relation to this
idea of forestry
is because we have now
organizational principles that are
faster and more
populated with information and
attention grabbing kinds of prompts.
We transform the same we
transform the same principle into a
harder to grasp process.
It becomes more complex. It becomes
harder to describe the process
of understanding that in terms of
forestry is kind of way more grounded.
When you apply that socially to this
kind of environment that we're talking
like internet or this highly
volatile and
virtual in principle environment,
it becomes much harder to assess what is
being pruned out or not. You just don't
know. It makes it more clear that there
is a process of pruning. You need to
have no control of what is being taken
out. You have no idea what's being
left away from your perspective of
attention.
So to this topic of intended
or unintended semantic pruning, I think
this has helped me identify attention.
If we want to talk about the semantics
or semiotics biosomiotics, whatever we
want to call it, of the letter E
in relationship to letter A, we're
looking for an account that might
convey leterness. But we're generalized
above enis or anus. So in
some ways we've erased or abstracted
generalized away from the particulars of
the sign meaning by
taking a semiotic perspective.
And so it's like we got into the game
to have a semantic account of biological
phenomena or of any phenomena for a
biological entity. Yet this
process in a sense
distances us from the particulars that
actually do grant it that meaning in
the actuality. Like if we walk into a
sacred space and it's like oh well,
that is just doing that over there and
this architecture is doing this and
because of the layout people must use
the room this way.
That's removed from
the actual meaning which
is the cause and consequence with the
organization and culture that we
discussed. But that prima fascia
account doesn't
generalize yet any generalization that
we make so that we can talk about
multiple places or multiple letters on a
common accounting framework is going to
remove those particularities.
So it's a very challenging catch 22.
Whether we want to really account for
the N equals one and maybe even live
and act and play and work in the N
equals one versus develop something that
might be satisfying and cut and dry,
but it's always going to be on the
sidelines with respect to what it
actually means.
But what do you mean? I don't understand
what you're getting at. Is it you mean
it's generalized or not generalized? I
didn't get that. When we generalize,
when we ask what words
mean, what words mean beyond any given
word, we've lost touch with what any
given word means.
But words are what they actually mean in
a situation. So it's just in this
scientific approach to meaning semiotics
and semantics we
have these two tensions or a
tension to. Reconcile between actually
giving an account of the meaningfulness
of the specific thing versus
taking a more scientific approach,
which would be gathering a group of
similar things and finding their
shared attributes, which out
of necessity must abstract, must crop
out features that
are empirically or anecdotally
taken to not matter. Like, we abstract
whether it was a Monday or Tuesday that
we did the experiment. We just combine
all of our replicates together when we
do the scientific analysis.
You mean if you generalize the practice,
you lose what you've been? If you
generalize it too much, you lose
everything that's meaningful to you in
terms of, like you formalize it and
then you have an empty semantics.
You have a semantics with no meaning
that can only be meaningful in terms of
how you apply that in terms of specific
practices. Yeah, it's like I have a
framework for the formal meaning of
letters within words, within sentences,
within paragraphs. And then it's like,
well, but now what's? Your next N equals
one word that you're actually going to
bring? It's not just
about building some abstract scaffold
for bigger and bigger boulders of
meaning. At some point, through our
embodied thought and action in
our experience, it is going to come down
into the particulars,
and it doesn't immediately seem clear
that simply generalizing further brings
us there.
Yeah, I don't really believe you can
have that kind of generalization. I
think we attempt to
build whatever what I see that's the
interesting aspect of the formal
thematics. You try to build this more
general understanding
that just formalizes to model, but for
that to be meaningful, it has to be
embedded in a way of practicing it,
like in a forestry practice. It has to
be embedded in a cultural environment in
which that can be actually observed
in terms of what happens when a
generative model is being updated or
not.
Is that what you mean? Because otherwise
I don't really understand how it
becomes too formal. It becomes too
abstract in terms of some I would not
understand what that is.
I'll think a little more Brynn or TJ.
Do you want to add any thoughts or
questions? Yeah, sorry.
I think I don't have a lot of context.
I've been following some of the
discussion but not attended a lot of
these calls. It's all.
Yeah, I don't know. I think I'm,
in general, just sort of interested in
trying to understand the relationship
between sorts
of constructionist epistemologies and
generative models and active inference
style stuff and how active
inference style, like yeah. What are the
philosophical commitments that active
inference involves with respect to
knowledge and epistemology? And there's
a sense in which rational choice models
often assume a certain sort of
objectivity to beliefs and then desires
are where most of the degrees of freedom
lie or something. Whereas there's a lot
of issue, like there's a lot of things
that come up once you start talking
about reflexivities where concepts
themselves become self fulfilling
prophecies, what your beliefs
about society ends up shaping the
society itself. So there's a sense in
which there's this codependence between
the object of knowledge and knowledge
about that object itself. And I think
yeah, I'm sort of interested in how the
active entrance ways of thinking about
this offers what perspectives
on those questions and stuff like that.
Thank you. Great questions.
So when you talk about the object of
knowledge and the knowledge itself and
active inference,
I think you can think of in
terms of this.
Well, there's a few ways to think about
that. I guess the
knowledge itself has to come
epistemically from where your agent is
actually embedded and situated.
Specifically in active inference, it's
embodied. It kind of needs to have
a model. The model is modeling a
body is modeling a body that is in the
world and it's all the time situated,
is never disconnected to its environment
and the history of that
environment. Right, yeah.
But if you think if you push that to the
object of that knowledge, I don't know
how different that
will how different
how can you differentiate that so
sharply when you talk about active
imprints? Because if
you think of in
terms of a generative model, what will
be updated is updated from
a prior that is always directed
in this body, in this situated realm.
So they sort of conflated as I see,
maybe I'm mistaken, but they sort of
conflate in how you're going to update
your generative model, which would be at
the same time what you know and what
the object of this knowledge?
Sorry, if I can just raise a question to
that. Yeah, so I think that there is a
sense in which with respect to
something that in epistemology would be
called self knowledge, there is a
question here that the active inference
agent has this model
that is situated in the body or in
its structure
and is also modeling that structure
itself. And there is this issue of the
belief is not unidirectionally dependent
on the object sort of a thing, but has
this feedback loop thing comes up there.
But there's another way in which I think
where this sort of thing comes, where
even if the object is outside of the
body of the knowledge, I think that
could still come up. So, for instance,
if an active inference agent lives in a
society of other active inference
agents, where currently all of them
defect on prisoners dilemma, but maybe
on further reflection, they would want
to again, I don't know what further
reflection would mean in the active
inference sense, but I'm just saying in
the intuitive sense, what would it mean
for them to go from one fixed point to
another fixed point where they're all
cooperating or something like that?
And that, I think,
is not clear to me. Like how that shift
can happen in active inference where
it's not just purely using the empirical
information to keep running the
mill of your free energy
equation but also recognizing
the contingencies and then identifying
those contingencies to make something
like shifts from one state to another.
Like if I model that the society is a
cruel space and if everyone models a
society as a cruel space, then we will
end up creating a society that is a
cruel space. But if only we could
recognize that our belief or our model
that society is a cool space is a
contingent belief and we could all
somehow negotiate or communicate and
shift to a different belief about what
society is and society is a kind place,
then we will end up creating that kinder
society or something. And that sort
of like a belief about the thing that
society is. It's not entirely within the
agent.
It has a weird intersubjective
character. So it's not entirely outside
of the agent either, but it's not
entirely internal to the agent either.
Or something. Yeah.
You can think of that like you're
talking about active inference. Action
comes first, right? You don't have the
knowledge inside your head waiting
for you to push that out of the action
has to come first. So if
you take that as a principle, an
organizing principle, it depends on the
contingency of your actions. The
possibilities might be limited by your
situated condition,
but they are limited. It doesn't mean
that you don't have a range of options
from that state space in which you can
navigate. So you can navigate it for the
good or for the bad, but it starts with
the action perception loop, starts with
the action. All out.
A few other pieces on that. TJ very good
point. Like when we see the
pragmatic component of action as self
fulfilling epistemic component of
action having to do with gaining
knowledge and the salience of
information. But the pragmatic component
is about bringing our observations into
alignment with our preferences. And then
you identified two related settings.
One of them is like pure intra
subjectivity like I expect myself or I
find myself or I habitually think about
x. Well, that's kind of a trivial self
fulfillment because thinking about
something is its own fulfillment.
And then when we're in this second
person or social space we
can agree on little performance art or
on a game and games give evidence to
that. That when people are able to
perform communication or message passing
such that new expectations or
preferences are set whether more
top down, like more seeing, like a state
or more laterally, more like collective
behavior then those regimes can be
embodied. And then you brought up a very
important point about the awareness of
the contingencies or awarenesses of
adjacent possibles or of
counterfactuals. So the body
might be we could model its morphology
as doing some computation but that
doesn't mean that the morphology has an
awareness or can explore a
counterfactual. Like bodies are not
always exploring every counterfactual
because Skin is in the game. But again,
mentally it's very cheap and easy to
consider counterfactuals and situational
awareness of social settings,
especially if it can be not just
understood but communicated, opens up a
space where we're all playing Prisoners
Dilemma. Now there's parameterizations
of Prisoners multi agent Prisoners
Dilemma where tragically, we just all
defect all day and never learn. There's
also parameterizations where you just
start all cooperating and never defect.
And then the interesting settings are
where there might be like phase
transitions or where a perturbation
moves the system from one attractor into
another attractor. So there's just a lot
of richness and that's the
work of building generative models and
that iterated modeling process to
unpack and refine.
And active inference isn't going to have
a stance on a Prisoner's dilemma. We can
use active inference to describe the
prisoner's dilemma, but active inference
isn't going to come down on literally
even a little two by two game theory
matrix. So we can then extrapolate
that active inference is not going to
come down with an opinion on something
significantly more
rich and real than a two by
two game theory matrix. And so that work
is what people enact in
applying active inference.
Right? And I think my question is
something like but insofar as humans
try to constantly improve their social
games, how can we model
that sort of a prior over your actions
or policies that enables that
sort of progressive, um,
improvements or something?
Well,
we are assuming that we're trying to
improve. We don't know that, but you can
model them as improving. But like
following Daniel's lead, we're talking
about these specific games and
contingencies these transitions from one
state to another. Specifically, if
you're talking about this modeling of
social actors and talking about several
actors, if your model involves several
of them, will not be really linear,
right? You don't have like an easy,
smooth transition of improvement you can
capture over time as modeling how
they might tend to go towards a
direction and understand that as
improvement. But that takes specific
iterations that will not be fully
linear. I guess specifically if you want
to understand Error and improvement
instead of Trier and Error but trier and
adding up into this Error like Error
improvement. But when you're modeling
specifically with dynamical systems,
for instance, you're not going to see a
full linear story and I don't think
you're going to see that if you're
modeling using active inference and
multiple agents.
I'll add one piece there. So how could
we go about modeling multiscale social
goals so we could think
about different citizens in a region
and the modeler is
going to choose what knowledge to
realize in the generative model, like
what you put into the calculator it's
going to calculate upon. Now this
happens to be an elaborate stochastic
method, but if we only tell
people, yeah, there's just your personal
income optimize for that, your
preference is to have that be higher,
well, then the simulation is going to
unfold a certain way. If we say, well,
there's your personal financial income
and then there's your city and then
there's your region, then that opens
up through different mechanisms.
Maybe an individual goes flat or
neutral on the personal in service of a
larger win at a higher level.
Well now what if the modeler says it's
not just about the financial income now
we're also going to have this secondary
criterion? Well now different agents
could attend differently to those two
different outcome variables.
And maybe there's one simulation where
50% only care about this and 50% care
about that and it works perfect or it
doesn't work.
It's like a broad surveying or
Lego set or grammar
or active inference ontology for
scoping very broadly and very
inclusively. But all
the work is in the real simulation
development and sweeping because
very little could be said about a
game theory game. If you didn't know
what the parameters were in the matrix,
you wouldn't know whether this
Prisoner's Dilemma was going to be like
an always cooperate or which agents with
which strategies would or wouldn't
cooperate if you don't know what the
matrix looks like. So before the
values have kind of been filled in,
it's just like actually describing the
adjacencies and the counterfactuals and
the contingencies of our scientific
model. But that's still
prior to having the model in hand.
So now we're looking at that tree in the
European forest and it's like, well, if
I had this tool, then I could cut it
down this way. If I had this tool, I
could cut it down this way or I could
wait. It's like that's.
Alternative actions about that tree.
Now in the social science setting,
discussion of different scientific
methodologies are like counterfactuals
about that social tree.
Yeah. And specifically, if you're
navigating these kinds of game
theoretical models, if that's what
you're interested in, you can even
define in terms of prisoners dilemma,
for instance, specific values
to see what happens when
everybody deflects
and how frequent modulate those
frequencies in terms of specific in
multiple iterations.
How are you going to build up the weight
for the tendency of deflecting?
Again, if your neighbor deflected once
and deflected twice or three times and
see how that will accommodate over
time how many times this agent will
change its behavior until it stops
changing the behavior. But you
don't really again,
you might use a Bayesian understanding
Bayesian model for that, but it not
necessarily explain it
does not necessarily explain the action
fully. I mean,
socially you're modeling only the
interest of that specific actor.
I have a slightly meta question, if I
can ask both of you. I'm not sure how
these calls usually go. I'm curious
what are your interests in active
inference? What brings you to active
inference and what do you think active
inference adds to our theoretical
understanding and in what ways or
something.
Lorena, go for it.
Well, I think I was
trying to touch upon that before and how
we can, if you're navigating, for
instance, behavior in terms of game
theory, this kind of modeling, if you're
talking about like trust games, for
instance, you're going to understand how
these two addict interactions evolve
over time, specifically over
interactions. But you don't have
an account of change because you have
very limited options of actions, and you
don't have an account also on scales.
And I think active influence tries to
edge a little bit an account on how you
can scale that and how
you can add more parameters into the
game and see how they evolve with
a more clear understanding,
some richer understanding. That, for
instance, when you talk about specific
interactions in game theory.
So that's one
aspect that active inference kind of
contributes. Another point is because
we have this parameterization
that is specifically in terms of
belief updating and also in terms of
dynamics, we are
always talking about agents that will be
situated and embodied and have a very
specific synchronization
with the environment all the time.
Because when you talk about active
inference, the action comes always
first. So you try to have a less
reductive model.
And when you want to model cultural
agents and collective action, I think
that's kind of desirable. That's what
you're looking for. Is it also your
area of interest? Sorry? Is it also
your area of interest.
Mine or is that Lorena's area of
interest? Lorena's, what do you sorry.
Like, my question was also like, what
brings you to active inference? And I
think you answered a lot of ways in
which active inference adds theoretical
value, but I wasn't sure if that was
also your subjective interest or
motivation. It's my subjective interest.
Yeah. I'm curious to see how that pans
out. Right. I'm interested in how that
helps us to think of this
type of phenomena,
and I'm very interested in how this
relationship from agents to collectives
and back again work.
And I think it might give us some well,
you give us some very insightful way of
modeling these relationships and
navigating it as you want, because this
feature of being scale free is kind of
helpful to looking things.
You can define your Markov
blanket in terms of are you interested
and see what happens.
I don't know. Yeah, I'll just give a few
thoughts, even though also, surely some
of these thoughts are scattered.
You asked TJ, what does active inference
add to our theoretical account of the
social? It does many things, in my
view, and that's what makes it so
valuable epistemically and
pragmatically. It gives us the
expressivity within a scale
to describe collective behavior and
across scales to describe nested
systems. So that brings continuity to
discussions of the social with broader
discussions of the biological,
ecological, computational, physical,
and so on. So that's a multiscaled
transdisciplinary element. Active
inference provides us with legible first
principles which can either be taken
instrumentally as just heuristics and
also in certain situations can be viewed
empirically as justifiable
first principles and then from those
legible first principles which are not.
English specific, they're already
in a space that has a
lot more possibility
and promise than, for example,
a mere enumeration of important
adjectives or nouns. We can
develop lists of important adjectives
and nouns when we have a broader
cognitive modeling framework. And so
this methodological turn then
supports just a tremendous diversity of
thought and work. Instead of asking
us to kind of go through the eye of the
needle and get on board with this one
ranking of features and then try to
apply it more broadly, that's like an
overfit before the Cart situation.
With Actimf, we can expand the
methodological discussion, connect it to
theoretical physics and mathematics in
ways that really haven't been seen
before, and then that opens up
more than it closes down. It brings up
more questions than it resolves in and
of itself, but it opens the questions
that can be resolved, like what
generative model can I make that will
keep the temperature in this building
livable? But active inference isn't
going to have a stance on what you
should do for that building. So we need
to, in a way, take a step in the
methodological direction,
which I see as moving towards active
inference to enable a million steps
in different directions.
I have a bunch of questions here.
I think one is probably just a reference
question. There are three topics that
I'll say. If you guys have any papers or
articles on those things, I would love
to get a reference. One is,
in what ways can we model a collection
or an aggregation of active inference
agents as a super agent?
Active inference, super agent or
something? And how does this
decomposition and aggregation
flexibility work in different contexts?
If there's work that tries to either
make informal commentary or formal
modeling either ways, I would love to
see that. Secondly.
Just on the first, check out the
previous section of this course on
collective behavior, where I reviewed
many such works. Great, thanks. Okay,
is it on the same notion? Is it linked
from the same notion. Thing all in the
same places and in the same playlist
with this course? Same syllabus? Yes.
Got it. Okay. The second is, is there an
active entrance account of,
say, markets or economic interaction
wherein your prices act as some
sorts of information signals? And can
you use active inference to then talk
about aggregation of market entities or
something? I'm guessing this would also
be covered in the same list. Indeed,
people have explored cognitive
economics, and people are working on it,
but that doesn't mean it's a done deal
theoretically or especially in practice.
So keep going. It's quite experimental
still, but there are a bunch of people
working on that, I guess. I don't
remember any specific paper right now,
but I can look it up and forward
to you. But yeah, it would be great.
I can drop my email address here. Yeah,
sure. The third is probably more
trickier than both of these, which is,
is there an active inference account of
natural language?
Yes. Thankfully, colleagues like Elliot
Murphy and others have explored
specifically the linguistic aspects of
natural speech. I think Lorena's lecture
and area of focus generalizes a
bit beyond specific natural language,
because we're talking about semiotics
and semantics in a more intermodal
sense. However, yes, there's been
limited work from a computational
linguistics and neurobiology perspective
on speech.
Okay, so then okay,
so you said something like first
principles stuff. When you're making a
commentary on what active inference
brings, I'm still often
struggling, what is active inference
offering? And I try to encounter
different things. I think I enjoy a lot
of philosophical questions that the
conversation opens up, but I'm still
very ambivalent about the theory. And
when I read this new book, which Friston
has not written but is a co author,
I don't remember the name of the book.
Yeah, I don't exactly remember. There's
a book, right, which is supposedly
supposed to be the canon, and Friston is
a co author, but in the. Preface, he
says, so that's the 2022
Par Friston Pazula textbook, right?
Par, yeah. I wouldn't quite
say it's the canon, since it's a short
book, but certainly it is a landmark
moment for the field. Right. And when I
read that, the one thing that bothered
me was it brings
up the helmet's free energy thing,
but it sort of argues it by fiat. Like,
okay, this is a simple principle. It can
model a lot of things, but that doesn't
tell me why I
should trust it. What is the reason to
act? Why does this principle lead to
cognition? Sure,
you've posited a very simple principle
and then said, hey, look, this simple
principle can explain so many things,
but well, it also explained things that
don't look like cognition, and I'm not
sure I got an
account of why that principle is works
or something. Lorena, go for it.
I'll think of some other ways to say it.
Yeah, you can think of modeling
by construction and modeling by first
principles, and modeling by first
principles. You have some limitations in
which you cannot fully explain some
things. But the virtue of the
model and how the first principle
organizes everything that comes along
with the model usually might be
sufficient or might be a useful
tool to help you explain that phenomena
that based on the first principle that
you were bringing along. And that's
one part of answering this question. I
think it might be a big question for the
field. Yeah, here's some short little
threads on that. Yeah. We can describe
maladaptive cognitive systems or
adaptive cognitive systems, whether
something's adaptive or not is always in
relationship to its niche, like the
foraging algorithm that works in the
desert doesn't necessarily work in the
rainforest. So these systems are not
like intrinsically adaptive or not.
We want to have natural language that
allows sentences that are valid and
invalid and have different kinds of
semantics. So again, this is just an
expressivity framework that enables
people to build cognitive models of high
reliability or important settings. Or
you could make something that looks just
like a beautiful circuit board and not
even worry about what the outcome is.
Yeah, for sure you can describe all
kinds of systems. That would be like
having a less than functional
methodological system. If we said,
well, we're doing a linear regression
framework but we only want positive
regressions, it's like, well, no, at the
methodological level, we want it to be
able to do any slope. So here in the
cognitive modeling setting, we want more
expressivity so that we can actually
construct the ones that we're interested
in. And then how does this really
do cognition? How is it that a first
principles like surprise minimization
or the bounding of surprise through free
energy, how can that really cover so
many cognitive phenomena?
That's the question and the play. But
how is it that Newton's laws of motion
can describe so many objects being
dropped off a tower? How is it that
Bayesian mechanics can describe so
many different priors being updated?
And so by understanding cognitive paths
as paths of least action, which is the
free energy principle, a wide variety
of models become
of a similar kind, now become
available. Yeah, whether that's useful
to a given person in a given setting.
Like if you make an active inference
model of your business, it doesn't mean
you're going to succeed. If you make a
self driving car with active inference,
it doesn't mean it's going to work.
This isn't a guarantee of success, but
it's a method that can be utilized. And
we know that the method reaches
different kinds of modeling outcomes and
supports subsequent perspectives and
models from where it reaches. But we
can't a priori limit where the method
reaches to only the successful ones or
only biological systems. Then we
wouldn't even have the expressivity to
talk about cognitive ecosystems with
synthetic intelligences.
And when you're talking about cognition
also we can use these kind of first
principles to model aspects of
cognition. But you might not necessarily
think that cognition is all encompassing
like that everywhere all the same, but
you can use that to model specific
things that you're interested in in
cognitive behavior, like adaptivity.
Does it give me any insight to
understand what is adaptive behavior,
for instance? And which kind of insights
do I get? Are they interesting? Are they
useful? So that's what the availability
that this kind of model bring along. So
you don't have to believe in the whole
story, but it gives you a lot of
leverage to ask questions and what
kind of questions you'll be asking.
Okay, so let's say that active inference
and free energy allows me to talk about
systems, but does
it also give me vocabulary to
then classify those systems in terms of,
let's say adaptivity would be one
property, but there could be other
properties in terms of how
rich the world model is or stuff like
that. If you have a
portfolio of generative models, you
could summarize them according to the TJ
statistic, you could summarize them
according to the number of nodes, you
could put them into a common environment
or different environments and summarize
their activity in any number of ways.
But we can't talk about
a ranking or a summarization of a
portfolio of generative models that's
not in hand. This is a framework that
lets us build those diverse generative
models and then in a very open ended way
do model comparison, model selection,
model adequacy, all the kinds of complex
systems engineering methods that
we want. And also
I would ask you, where do you see
a peer or a comparison first
principle? Active inference has legible
first principles which are reflected in
the active inference ontology and
expressions using it, which can be
represented in natural language. So
that's the talking about it, but it's
not only represented in natural
language, other frameworks have other
first principles that may or may not be
legible and people may choose different
paths to go down for whichever number of
reasons. Well, you can compare them,
right models like they have the virtue,
you can compare them and see which one
gives you the best insight that you're
looking for. Yeah, I think something
that I could compare to active inference
is like say the Bayesian utility
maximization thing which has a different
ontology. I'm not a fan of that either.
I'll just note that Bayesian utility
maximization is a special case of free
energy where there's no Epistemic value,
all you have is Pragmatic value and so
a. Special diminished not
necessarily. You have value of
information and you have explore exploit
trade offs in Beijing utility
maximization as well.
If you load into your utility function,
if you can beg the question and load
Epistem into Pragma, you're right, then
all you need is Pragma. But in expected
free energy we have Epistemic and
Pragmatic value, which is what enables
us this expressivity. But I think we're
aligned on that.
Right? I think I'm somewhat also
slightly confused because in the
Bayesian utility between the languages,
comparing the languages as such in the
Bayesian utility maximization, the
exploration parts that are prioritized
based on your X anti estimation
on the value of information. Whereas I'm
not sure that holds true for the active
inference model as well, that the
Epistemic exploration is prioritized or
valued in terms of some of the same
Pragmatic thing as well.
You'll have a lot to explore
and learn. You can make a model that is
80 20 or 2080 or 100 and zero between
Epistemic and Pragmatic. There's nothing
we. Can say across generative models
about whether active inference
prioritizes epistem or not because you
can make a model that's 100% or zero.
Sorry, I meant more like does active
inference allow us to talk about systems
that the Beijing utility maximization
doesn't allow us to talk about? I'm
talking particularly about expressive
power of the language. Are there
things that the Bayesian utility
maximization can talk about that active
inference cannot? Other things that
active inference can talk about that
Bayesian utility maximization cannot?
Two short answers. One short answer.
Utility maximization must cram
epistemic value into Pragmatic value.
We gain more expressivity when we can
articulate out Pragmatic value, which is
the alignment of preferences with
observations from epistemic value,
which is information gain. So that's a
huge articulation. And the second thing
is when you're in an anything
maximization framework, when you're in a
utility function now, again, begging the
question how you constructed this
function that you're trying to maximize.
But when you're in a maximization
framework, we have a well known set of
approaches for finding local and global
maxima using optimization or
maximization frameworks. What active
inference uniquely provides is it
describes the path that that cognitive
thing takes as a path of least
action that minimizes surprise.
So instead of climbing to the top of the
hill up, are we on a foothill or are we
on the biggest hill? We're like a ball
rolling to the bottom of the hill,
finding the least surprising path. Now,
that least surprising path can still
include novelty and information gain,
but it turns out to be a lot more
tractable and connected with statistical
physics and quantum mechanics. When we
talk about the path of least action,
ball rolling down the hill rather than
this sort of question beg on top of a
mountain climbing adventure Bayesian
utility approach.
But it's up to each person to feel how
they want to feel. Yeah, and I
think that a little bit what's in the
book as well, when you take the low and
high road for free energy principle,
right? Because how much you
want to have your utility
maximization function being disconnected
to the pragma, to the action.
Because when you're modeling behavior,
it will be hard to do that
independently. Like, you have a lot of
you have way more assumptions. You are
committing to much a greater level of
assumptions for your utility function if
you don't do that.
Because with the action first, that
Pragmatizes, you have
reasons to describe, have reasons to
believe why that information gain works
the way that it does, you can leverage
some explanations on that. Without it,
you have a model that has more
assumptions. And I think if you have a
model with less assumptions, it's always
healthier, let's say so,
yeah. So I think that does talk about
the comparative analysis of the
expressivity. But I would also say as a
metaphor that I'm not happy with either
of those languages. I suspect
that both of those languages claim
certain ontological assumptions. And I'm
always suspicious and wait, but where
are these ontological assumptions coming
from? A few other points.
We tap into an absolutely meaningful
nexus of statistical methods and message
passing schemes with active inference.
If you can state something in the active
inference ontology and construct a
generative model then message
passing algorithms can be deployed.
That contractably compute that model.
So that's absolutely nontrivial.
Otherwise it's possible just to get
wrapped up in some analytical formalism.
But then once you want to do that on a
4K video now you're on square zero
with the computer engineering. This is
not that way. And then I will respond to
your metapoint with a metapoint, which
is when we've enumerated the
alternatives, the one that we like best.
Personally, I feel happy with. I'm also
open to new alternatives arising. But
being unhappy when all things considered
is in play, why?
What bothers you specifically on the
ontology of the
active imprint? Yeah,
I think I'm still looking for
I don't know what exactly I'm looking
for, but I feel dissatisfied with the
account given for why helmet's free
energy, least action thing like,
is the central thing here or something.
Why does it work? Why does this
principle? Yeah.
There'S a lot of funny answers I could
give there. Yeah, that delta,
that discrepancy, that's curiosity
and that's the space of the open and
that's learning and that's your unique
contribution to make and that's
everything. So that's not just a thorn
in your shoe. That's like our
experience of action amidst uncertainty,
which is the water we're in.
And so whether we take a higher
order narrative perspective on that
discrepancy being dissatisfying or that
discrepancy being satisfying, I think
it's pretty I just need to. Minimize my
surprise there. Yeah, and you can choose
to minimize your surprise through your
attention. You can choose to minimize
surprise at a higher narrative order.
Like, I am satisfied and complacent that
I don't understand number theory but I
use numbers to count objects around me.
So that discrepancy and understanding
knowing that there's 1000 years of
research that could be done on numbers,
it doesn't unsettle me. But for someone
else that might be unsettling and that
might lead them to ruminate. It also
might lead them to do a PhD in number
theory. So just different paths for
different individuals and contexts.
But there's always so many technical and
meta levels with active.
So I don't want to keep you guys over
time, but I would ask one last reference
based thing, which is are there active
inference accounts of seeing like, a
state phenomena in any literature?
I think I heard you mention it once, so
I was like, yeah, look at this.
Yeah. Check out live stream 33 series.
But also this course that we're
literally actually enacting in with Avel
is where these accounts come to
roost and where we're creating a space
to develop it. And it's not a cathedral
for us just to spectate at today, but if
you want to make an active inference
generative model of whatever social
setting, when you have the model in
hand, a lot of your questions will be
sidestepped.
Okay, where is the 33 thing that you
mentioned? If you go to the page with
all of our Institute live streams and
look in the Live Stream series, like the
paper discussions in the 33 series,
there's a dot zero video with background
and context. And then we have a dot one
and a dot two conversation with the
authors. But Avel, who's also the course
coordinator for this course and research
Avel's and colleagues work has
heavily built on the seeing like a
state, thinking like a state optimal
grasp all these different topics.
I'm on your YouTube channel. I'm
slightly finding it hard to find the
thing. If you look
up Live Stream 33.0 or
if you go to in the video description of
any video where it says all live streams
here, go there and search for but you'll
find it. And you can always email us or
get in contact. But yeah, and I think a
sales paper Thinking Like a State also
can help you a lot to understand how
active inference modeling is useful for
the social sciences in comparison to
other types of modeling. He makes a
comprehensive description. Interesting.
Great, thanks. And this is our first
iteration on this course. We are going
to continue bringing new information to
the table and supporting individuals who
want to build generative models around
this area, whether it's part of an
internship program or part of a course
credit or different kinds of programs
that we'll be able to develop.
But this is the real thing,
and we're able to work with people who
want to think and do. Makes sense
indeed. Any closing thoughts, TJ?
Then I will go and then Lorena with the
last word. No, this was
great. Thanks for the conversation.
Thank you. Well, thank you for Brennan
TJ for joining Lorena for the lecture.
This was a fun discussion. We never
really know where how it's going to go,
but I'm glad that we could cover so
many of these topics and probably
raise more questions and footholds
than door slams. So thank you again,
Lorena. Yeah, thank you for inviting
me. And I think active inference holds
a lot of space for experimenting as
well. Some things you try to see if they
make sense and if they're going to hold
up and open new questions, and that
might be an interesting aspect of
the framework itself.
Thank you, everybody. Thank you,
everybody, for the great live chat
comments. There's a lot there. I
couldn't read it all. So till next time.
Bye.